[Música]
hace más de un siglo los migrantes
judíos de europa del este- animados por
ideas socialistas fundaron en 1909 el
primer kibutz a orillas del mar de
galilea también llamado lago tiberíades
pocos hubieran imaginado que 40 años
después más de 70 mil personas habrán
unido a su movimiento que promovía la
unidad y la ayuda mutua más de 100 años
después de su creación el lugar ha
cambiado mucho hoy en día las compañías
cotizan en bolsa la agricultura está
totalmente industrializada se exportan a
muchos países animales como peces con
muchas ganancias si bien el kibutz sigue
formando una parte central de los
asentamientos judíos y del estado de
israel en esta era su faceta es mucho
más empresarial france24 fue para allá a
observar qué es lo que queda de esa
utopía original y conocer también más de
su vida en la actualidad esto es boleto
de vuelta a los kibutz
[Música]
llegamos aquí con la intención de
construir un kibutz arrancamos con nada
era una vida bastante miserable
cuando se tiene mucho dinero se puede
ser socialista
no somos amigos avanzamos como el mundo
entero
los kibutz están rodeados por una
alambrada que se volvió un muro y quise
romper ese muro
[Música]
la nueva generación no se dedica lo
suficiente vive cómodamente tengo la
costumbre de a decir que fueron
alimentados con una cuchara de oro y ni
siquiera la sostenían
jajaja
a unos cuantos metros de la playa
jardines cuidados casas idénticas y
carritos de golf
me llamo sandrine llegué amagan michael
hace 27 años madre de tres niños
el kibutz para mí es fantástico es el
mejor lugar de lyon es sobre todo uno de
los más ricos de israel es maga michael
hay una cancha de fútbol fábricas un
zoológico y una clínica pero el kibutz
siguió siendo si tu film colectivista en
hebreo quedan tan sólo 30 en el país
el kibutz está dividido en área
comercial aquí llegamos al área
comercial de cuidados cosmética de litio
el manicure que nos permite no salir al
exterior los precios son muy ventajosos
para los miembros del kibutz vas a tener
eso en todas las áreas
gracias a aarón
y muchos servicios son gratuitos se lava
la ropa se plancha y se dobla los niños
son cuidados los adultos mayores cuentan
con ayuda a domicilio y sobre todo ya
había pagado nunca arriendo alguno en
maghama maikel
en los años 60 mir creció en una casa de
niños separado de sus padres hoy en día
el tamaño de su casa depende en parte de
su descendencia
ok
[Música]
el más joven se llama adán en este
momento está en el ejército cuando
tienes dos tres hijos obtienes una casa
más grande es por ello que vivimos aquí
no tuvimos que pagar un millón o dos
millones de shekels para comprar una
casa una casa cerca al mar next to the
beach
un nivel de vida estimado en 25.000
shekels por pareja es decir seis mil
doscientos euros
es muy difícil estimar si es mucho o no
porque no se paga por el coche o por la
casa en general el dinero sirve para
comprar alimento ropa para ir a
restaurantes ese tipo de cosas o gastos
actualmente en ir es el secretario
general del club pero los cargos cambian
cada cuatro años el día de mañana tal
vez sea granjero pero su salario seguirá
siendo el mismo aquí todos los ingresos
se redistribuyen en el kibutz y el
dinero es distribuido en función de la
composición del hogar todos los solteros
reciben la misma suma todas las parejas
con un hijo lo mismo y así sucesivamente
los tiempos no siempre han sido tan
fáciles ella es una de las pioneras del
kibutz tenía 23 años en 1949 cuando todo
era pantano
[Música]
hoy en día es muy grande y parece muy
bello pero los inicios fueron difíciles
porque no había nada no había dinero
dormimos en carpas y cabañas sin
electricidad sin nada hoy en día su
nieto tiene 23 años y en parte gracias
al trabajo de su abuela cuenta con una
vida muy distinta me reúno con mis
amigos en el comedor almorzamos juntos
disfruto la vida comunitaria nosotros
los jóvenes nos divertimos nos reunimos
todas las noches en nuestros
apartamentos con los amigos nos reímos
nos contamos nuestras vidas y la nevera
es cierto hoy en día cada uno cuenta con
una nevera una cama y todo el resto es
por ello que para mí es inimaginable
ponerme en el lugar de los adultos
mayores a mi edad cuando llegaron y no
había nada
de hecho como el resto del mundo el
kibutz ha evolucionado hoy en día las
fábricas cotizan en bolsa la agricultura
está totalmente industrializada estos
peces se exportan a todas partes algunos
a precio de oro podemos obtener mil o
dos mil euros por un solo pescado
mira afirma que los valores no han
cambiado así hoy en día el individuo
esté por encima del grupo
y la gente quiere tomar sus propias
decisiones cada vez más entonces el
kibutz se volvió cada vez más
capitalista pero en comparación con el
resto del mundo somos muy socialistas es
muy agradable tener dinero cuando eres
socialista es muy difícil no contar con
él
aunque socialista rico y cada vez más
aislado con el paso de las generaciones
la tendencia es cada vez más recibir que
dar
es como una sociedad de asistidos al fin
de cuentas porque afuera es necesario
luchar para ganar su pan aquí el pan
está en la mesa no es necesario hacer
nada para obtenerlo el kibutz no podrá
durar creo que de aquí a cuatro o cinco
años habrá grandes cambios
por aquí el éxito es tal que nadie
abandona el kibutz por consiguiente la
demografía explota dentro de poco magán
michael ya no podrá garantizarle el
mismo nivel de vida a sus miembros
se dirige hacia una privatización
absorbido por un sistema económico
liberal carcomido por tentaciones
individualistas la gran mayoría de los
kibutz se resignó desde hace tiempo al
sistema de la privatización un giro de
180 grados que empezó aquí en the gang
ya hace 13 años
me llamo goded gun año nací en degaña en
1940 y en 1997 entendí que todo en lo
que creía y pensaba hasta ahí es decir
el modo de vida de los kibutz es
socialismo y todo lo que me gustaba de
hecho llegaba a su fin
[Música]
a principios de los años 2000 oded
dirigía el kibutz fue él quien creó la
primera comisión para iniciar la
privatización una lección difícil porque
the gang ya no es cualquier kibutz es el
primero la madre de todos
y este fue el primer comedor allá a la
pastelería y atrás estaban las primeras
duchas un rincón para las mujeres otro
para los hombres y otro para los niños
el edificio cambio de apariencia varias
veces hoy en día es un museo todo empezó
con un puñado de hombres y mujeres
deseosos de liberarse de un pasado
doloroso y de construir un hombre nuevo
tenía solamente un vestido si una mujer
debía ir a la ciudad despida si las
otras también querían ir debían esperar
el regreso a la primera y luego se
intercambiaban los vestidos
111 años más tarde los vestigios de la
guerra permanecen pero las casas de
cemento reemplazaron a las de madera y
poco a poco con el avance de la
privatización los edificios se fueron
vaciando el world out for the people el
papel de jane aquí durante años estuvo
la casa de los adultos mayores y los
enfermos que no podrían administrarse
solos hace algunos años las cosas
cambiaron porque prefieren estar en casa
asistidos por ayuda domiciliaria y
tuvieron wins ámbar intuit vívidamente
poder
ahora verán ya es una vieja dama
silenciosa que trata desesperadamente de
atraer nuevas personas u otras que
regresen algunos jóvenes que se fueron
hace algunos años regresan hoy en día
porque la sociedad israelí no hace
concesiones el kibutz ya no es lo que
era uno de los pocos vestigios del
espíritu original que sigue uniendo es
el comedor común
y más
por costumbre o comodidad algunas
decenas vienen a almorzar todos los días
pero las reglas han cambiado
en aquella época al principio no se
buscaba una bandeja te sentabas y te
servían en la mesa ahora los miembros
del kibutz deben tomar bandejas comen en
la mesa y luego deben recoger las
condiciones han empeorado y ahora
pagamos por todo en aquella época todo
estaba a disposición
[Música]
comidas pagas salarios diferenciados
verán ya están muy lejos de la historia
exitosa de málaga michael
nosotros no decimos capitalismo hablamos
de privatización pri
acción quiere decir que distribuimos
pero cada vez que privatizamos podemos
decir que nos volvemos más capitalistas
que socialistas
un capitalismo presente por todas partes
en el interior de las casas
bajas de loja y alineaciones
esta cocina no existía antes de la
privatización yo tenía una cocina muy
pequeña hasta la mesa aquí incluso desde
la privatización esta casa no me
pertenece
en este momento trabajamos en un acuerdo
de afiliación para que así sea para mis
hijos no para mí
y dejar una herencia era impensable en
los kibutz de antaño pero para evitarle
la certeza de una muerte el movimiento
se flexibilizó hoy en día existen tribus
religiosos kibutz ecológicos e incluso
kibutz en la ciudad
[Música]
me llamo nominación vivo en sdérot desde
hace 33 años y decidimos establecer un
nuevo modelo de vida colectiva en israel
un nuevo modelo de vida social el kibutz
urbano
en estos kibutz urbanos no hay trabajo
agrícola ni barreras físicas ni mentales
el kibutz big band cuenta con una sola
regla ninguno
en live with queríamos venir aquí y
vivir con personas de medios culturales
psicológicos y sociales diferentes en la
ciudad y tener una vida capitalista no
queremos vivir con 700 personas mil
personas queremos mantener nuestra
intimidad ideológica y socialmente
social índice
los miembros de este equipo urbano están
muy implicados en la vida educativa de
sdérot regamos las plantas y también las
tres palmeras que están en los barriles
y la línea de las plantas fértiles al
lado de las piedras grandes también las
nuevas plantas que se encuentran a lo
largo de la línea de riego así como
nómica amram nació en un kibutz a la
antigua y ya no se reconocía en su
evolución en cuanto el estado fue creado
el gobierno asumió el papel que ocupaban
hasta aquí los kibutz y a partir de ahí
los kibutz comenzaron a aislarse y
creciendo yo tenía la sensación de que
el kibutz estaba desconectado y no hacía
parte de la sociedad israelí
gemma lights de élite
algo que los motivó a salir de su
comodidad y a irse al sur a sdérot
ciudad pobre pegada a la franja de gaza
y blanco frecuente de los morteros de
hamas
[Música]
de los serveis
aquí el traumatismo relacionado con los
morteros es frecuente en los niños
i
de la hoya
ania más tarde
vale vale esto se verá reflejado
[Música]
el primero es la respiración y luego
soltar
[Música]
hoy en día la gente entiende que
necesita una comunidad conectarse con
los demás pero debe entender que la
solución no es necesariamente un kibutz
encerrado
y corre el riesgo de no ser más solo
nueve personas ponen su dinero en común
los otros hicieron otra elección si al
lazo social no en cuanto a compartir los
recursos
desafortunadamente debo reconocerlo
porque me gustaría mantener el mismo
sistema económico pero la mayoría no
quiere entonces debo aceptarlo
tradicional privatizado urbano
[Música]
el kibutz todavía sionista y mucho menos
socialista trata de sobrevivir
pero se aleja cada vez más de su lema
historia de cada quien según sus
capacidades para cada quien según sus
necesidades
y
[Música]
hasta aquí el boleto de vuelta a los
kibutz si desea ver nuevamente este
reportaje lo invitamos a visitar
france24 puntocom
[Música]